[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAUL FURNICA: OK, the screen
size is really small, so it's
kind of weird.
But this is a live
API [INAUDIBLE]
from this URL, so you
just click on it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAUL FURNICA: --I can explain
what happens.
But most of the time, it's just
explaining, oh, that's
behind this.
So we've done a request to
retrieve [INAUDIBLE] metadata.
That way, you can figure
from the URL.
And then we have a web interface
where you can try
any API call directly without
actually [INAUDIBLE]
tool or using a [INAUDIBLE].
So you just [INAUDIBLE]
web interface.
You have links to this
interface later on--
actually, on the last slide
on the resources.
And it's a really cool interface
that allows you to
specify the parameters.
But if a parameter is like a
[INAUDIBLE] parameter, you can
actually choose from the values
allowed and so on.
So it's a way to discover the
API and get into YouTube APIs
and YouTube, in particular.
On the response, you just get
metadata about video.
So kind of looks like this.
This is the first view
I'm giving you.
I'm going to go back to
it and show you more.
So in the first slide at the
top, I'm going to walk you
through the API structure
and terminology.
And the way I'm going to do that
is I'm going to slowly
start taking the base URL and
complete it until we get to a
full request that we can
fire against the API.
I'm going to explain every
single path and term that we
have on the way.
So first thing to note is that
the YouTube API is now hosted
at googleapis.com.
It only works on HTTPS.
And very first part of
the path is YouTube.
At googleapis.com,
you can find any
API that Google creates.
So you can find,
like, G+ APIs.
You can find contacts--
sorry.
Well, contacts works, too, but
Gmail, Calendar, all APIs are
under their own name.
And then the very first thing
you'll see that is particular
to YouTube is the
version of API.
The version of the API is,
as you might know,
a versioning API.
It's just naming of a particular
schema of the API.
Minor versions are usually
backwards-compatible, and they
add to the API schema.
Major versions are
backwards-incompatible, and
they change the schema in a
non-reusable way from an
[? app-forward ?]
perspective.
The naming, in particular,
is v major dot minor.
It's normal, so what
you would expect.
And it's part of the URL, so
that makes it really clear
which version you're using to
contact the YouTube API.
YouTube APIs are all RESTful.
And does everybody understand
what RESTful as an API means?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
RAUL FURNICA: Cool, awesome.
So in that sense, we
have data models.
We have a layer of this logic.
So I'm going to talk about both,
and then I'm going to
describe them, what do they
mean, the YouTube API.
And first thing in the
terminology that I want to
introduce is collections.
Collections, you can take it
as the sum of all resources
that are of the same type.
So collections would be anything
that, on the product
side, we would call nouns.
So anything that YouTube--
or the users of YouTube--
define as a noun, like
playlists or a video, it,
in the end, forms the
collections.
So this next part of the URL, it
identifies which collection
you want to work on.
I've listed here all the
collections we support right
now in the API.
And we're going to add on them,
and we're going to get
to the point-- like in v3 right
now, we have less than
we had in v2.
But we're going to get into
the point that we have
everything that we had
in v2, and we're
going to add some more.
The main parts are, as I already
mentioned, videos,
playlists, and channels.
That's the main defining nouns
of the YouTube product.
On top of that, there is
activities, search, and
subscription.
Those are a bit more special.
Activities are more about the
social side of YouTube, so you
follow other people's
activity.
You subscribe to other
people's activity.
You see what they're
doing on YouTube.
You get to discover new
content via them.
And in a sort of
weird way, even
recommendations in playlist.
And when YouTube thinks you
should be watching this video,
that comes up as an activity,
as a recommendation.
YouTube tells you or thinks
this is good for you.
Search is another collection,
but I'm going to detail that
probably later, because
we actually
reworked search in v3.
And subscriptions is just
videos, so you can get to, and
the channels, you subscribe
to them.
By introducing collections,
I already talked
about resources a bit.
So resources is very
hard to define.
I mean, it's pretty clear what
it is, but if I were to define
it, I would say it's just like
an identifiable unit
of data in an API.
Identifiable is the
important part.
So every resource has
a resource ID.
The resource ID is unique and
can point to that particular
resource only.
The resource IDs are, however,
not unique amongst different
collections.
So a video ID may collide
with a playlist ID.
We don't necessarily care about
keeping resource IDs
unique the entire way, which
is something that we
used to do in v2.
But we just found out that that
was really hard to use,
and people got confused because
they always had to
take the YouTube ID that you
would know from a website URL
and pre-plan something to make
it look like an API resource.
So in v3, we're reusing the
same resource IDs as the
website does.
So if you take the video IDs
from the website URL, you can
just type it in to the API
and use the same thing.
That, as I said, may cause
collision in some different
resources, but you just need to
be aware that this is the
video that I'm talking about,
[? where it still ?] plays.
And the chance is pretty
low as well.
Again, they're the same as the
YouTube nouns-- so it's video,
playlist, and channel.
And the resource ID, like right
here, you can see the
collection is videos.
And then after, we're already
moving into the parameters
that we're setting
on this API call.
That's id= and then the value.
And then there are some
extras to the request.
And I'm going to explain
a bit later.
But if you take this request as
it is, and you [INAUDIBLE]
API server, you would
get a response.
So that's already a fully
built request.
So we get some [INAUDIBLE]
simple version, collection,
or resource ID.
How does a video resource
look like?
So YouTube is about videos.
I don't know if I should
mention that.
But since videos are the main
resource of YouTube, so we--
oops.
That is true to the
API as well.
Video resource is the most
complicated resource we have
in the YouTube API, as well,
in terms of schema and the
number of things you can
retrieve from it.
And I just took here
the main important
fields for YouTube resource.
And it's exactly what
you would expect.
It's the time the video has
uploaded to YouTube.
It's the channel the video
is uploaded into.
It's the title, the description,
the thumbnails,
and a categoryId and tags.
This allows you to render the
visual snippet of a video, and
even start playback on an
embedded player I didn't
include that here, but
that's there as well.
There is a lot of information
extra that you can request
with specific requests.
Sure.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
RAUL FURNICA: Key properties.
So that's a very
good question.
So in v2, if you noticed--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
RAUL FURNICA: Oh, OK.
Sorry.
To repeat the question,
thumbnails has the key.
And the question is, what
is the key for, and
what does it mean?
Thumbnails is basically
a map, in JSON terms.
And the reason it is a map is
that we found out in version
2, when it was released, people
started depending on
the order of the thumbnails'
returned--
particular order.
So people would expect that
thumbnail, too, is of size 144
by [? 102 ?] pixels.
And when we needed to introduce
new thumbnails, we
always had the issue that we
can't insert it in the first
or second place, because
that matters.
But even in the last place,
[INAUDIBLE] other people,
because they make assumptions
about the number
of thumbnails available.
So to solve all this, we
turned it into a map.
And they key's actually the
name of the thumbnail.
So it's going to be
named default.
If you don't care, use
the default one.
If you want the HD thumbnail,
you're going to use the name
HD thumbnail is all.
And that means it's not
particularly ordered.
You identify by name what
thumbnail you want to use.
There is another thing that
I've highlighted here, and
that's kind.
Kind is a field that every
single resource in
a YouTube API has.
And it defines the type of that
resource, if you want.
So they're all going to be
youtube# and then the name of
the resource, so video,
in this case.
This is there because in any
JSON response, looking at just
the resource, you cannot
tell what type it is.
So if you want to know, for
some reason, then that
basically gives you
that information.
And if you're wondering, this is
the schema that the API is
defining completely.
And it's based on JSON
schema, if you note.
And you can retrieve this
information at runtime from
our servers at any
time you want.
So the schema is public
and discoverable.
Now we're getting into something
that is specific to
the YouTube API, and it's
new for version 3.
And that's parts.
So we discovered that our
resources are very
[INAUDIBLE].
And in order to retrieve a
particular resource, you might
get a 100-kilobytes response,
even, for a video in version
2, for instance, which is really
a lot for bandwidth
consumption.
So people need better control
in what they're retrieving
about that resource.
And also, we need a more
marginal response and marginal
resources, in particular.
However, a video is still a
video, and it means many
things to YouTube.
So if you're asking an uploader
what a video means,
it might be just the bytes he
uploaded and then the type of
description of the video
from upload metadata.
But if you're asking
an advertiser--
and advertisers are
users, too--
then you're basically finding
out that they have very
different needs related
to video.
They don't care that much about
the title maybe, but
they care a lot more about the
stats-- how many times was
this video watched, how many
times was this video embedded
on a particular site, or
which sites was it
embedded on and so on.
So analytics, in that sense, is
much more important there.
So in order to not have
different APIs for all this,
we still call that resource.
So video, we came
out with parts.
Parts are a grouping of fields
that makes sense to be both
managed and retrieved
at the same time.
And every single resource we
make against the YouTube API
version 3 requires that you
specify the parts you want to
fetch on that resource.
If it's a write operation, then
it basically means that
you're just operating
that part alone.
And every single part can be
read or written all by itself,
so [? independently. ?]
Or you can do that on multiple
parts at the same time.
There's no way to say, give me
all the parts today, which is
good for us because it allows
us to add new parts without
changing backwards-compatibility
or
without having to break
apps already there.
Because if apps would start
depending on certain parts
being there or not being
there, that would be a
backwards-incompatible change.
So this is good for us.
This is good for our clients.
And it really gives a lot of
control over the bandwidth for
every client app.
And the bandwidth is
really important,
particularly in YouTube.
So I'm going to give
examples later on.
But to start with, let's look
at two particular parts of
video difference.
One is statistics, one I talked
about a bit in the
analytics use case.
And another one is the status.
So statistics, for instance, is
much more interesting for
people that are looking into how
is this video doing, how
is it shared, how many people
like it or dislike it or
comment on it?
And this second status part is
much more about controlling
privacy of the video, and it's
much more important for an
uploader perspective,
for instance.
Or it's much more important from
a playback perspective.
If the video is private, you
can only do a playback for
that video, right?
So you can't see.
So the two are relatively
different, but you do get a
choice to say, I want both of
them, or I want one of them,
or I want none of
them, basically.
There are two parts that are
generic enough that show up on
every single resource.
One of them is the id part.
It doesn't make sense to return
a resource without
returning its ID, so there is
no need to call out the id
part in the part parameter.
You can just assume it's always
going to be returned.
And the second is a snippet,
which kind of goes with the
philosophy that if you say
YouTube resource, it should
have a visual presentation
or a thumbnail.
It's kind of something we're
trying to introduce in every
single operation that the
YouTube API supports.
We didn't have that in version
2, and people had a lot of
problems trying to retrieve
thumbnails that are about to
resource, but not necessarily
the resource, not necessarily
having a thumbnail directly.
Like, for instance,
subscription, it's a channel
you subscribe to.
But in order to get a thumbnail
for that in version
2, you have to actually take
your channel ID from the
subscription and then fire
another request against the
channel's feed, and then
get the thumbnail.
In this case, we're just saying
we want to make it easy
for people to visualize any
YouTube resource and put it on
a web page.
So that's all the fields
you need to
build this small snippet.
If you need a lot more, then you
have other options to get
more detail.
But we're kind of inlining
a bit of data to
help you out there.
Now we're moving to the business
logic [INAUDIBLE], so
basically on the operations
side.
So I've been talking about the
resources in particular-- so
collections, resources, or
data model, collection as
resources, IDs, and parts.
And now let's see what
kind of calls we can
make against the API.
So in terms of business
logic, we can define
the concepts as services.
Services are pretty much
related to collections.
So every single service
operates on a single
collection and only
one collection.
And it allows management of that
collection, so you can do
both reads and writes on that
particular collection.
In that sense, they're
all linked to
the collections name.
So there is a ChannelService,
there is a VideoService, there
is a PlayerService and a
PlaylistService and a
SearchService, and so on.
Services, in particular, handle
all the logic around
the authentication, around
privacy, ACLs for accessing
the data, and so on.
For authentication, we use OAuth
2.0 in version 3, and
only OAuth 2.0.
And [INAUDIBLE] to describe the
service methods, this is
just by the book.
It's not particular to
the YouTube API.
Any RESTful API would
do the same.
We only support list, insert,
update, and delete.
First one is a read.
The last one is a write.
And the syntax is dictated by
HTTP in the RESTful APIs.
So in order to do a list, you
have to do a HTTP GET call.
In order to do an insert, you
have to do an HTTP POST call,
HTTP PUT for update,
and HTTP DELETE
for deleting a resource.
So in the RESTful APIs, the verb
of the HTTP request gives
you the method that is
going to be invoked
on the server side.
The URL is going to give you the
rest of the signature of
the method that is
being invoked--
that is being called.
In the case of inserts and
updates, so POST and PUT,
there has to be a request body
that contains the resource
that is being affected
by the write.
So in the case of insert, it's
going to contain a resource
that is being created, or the
metadata on the video that is
being uploaded, for instance.
In the case of update, it's
the resource that is being
altered, so the new title that
you want to set on a video,
for instance.
AUDIENCE: Is that [INAUDIBLE]
ID in the update?
RAUL FURNICA: Good question.
So we noticed in version
2 that the [INAUDIBLE]
between the specification in URL
and the data coming in a
request body.
So in version 2, we had this
issue where, in inserts, the
ID was in the request method
as well as in the
URL and in the body.
And what do we do when in
conflict, like when you're
telling us in the body that you
want to update video ID x,
but in a request parameter,
you say you y?
So in that case, we've have
to reject the request.
So we just want to make it
simple and reduce that
duplication.
So the POST actually has always
been clear, because you
don't have the ID part to
create, but the edit is really
where the question is.
The PUT would contain the
resource ID in the resource
you're editing.
And actually, that
[INAUDIBLE].
And that allows us to even go
further and edit multiple
resources at the same time.
The DELETE, however, because
it's a simple call, and
because the request is in the
body, and we actually, as much
as we want to leave that out.
So it's hard to put a body in
the request, [INAUDIBLE].
So for the DELETE, we're taking
the ID and the URL.
And another particular thing
that the YouTube API did that
is not necessarily specific to
all RESTful APIs-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you [INAUDIBLE]?
RAUL FURNICA: The question
was, is there a symmetry
between the five types
of methods and--
AUDIENCE: No, the symmetry
between-- so [INAUDIBLE].
RAUL FURNICA: So the GET URL
looks very similar to what--
AUDIENCE: The parameter
[INAUDIBLE].
RAUL FURNICA: Ah, I
see what you mean.
So we don't support
the exact same
parameters on list and delete.
But we try to for as
much as we can.
So by the bulk deletes, which
would be if you delete
something by author, you would
delete everything, it's
something we're looking into.
We don't have it
yet right now.
But it's a big question if we
want it, because it's super
powerful, but in the same time,
it's super damaging if
you do it by mistake.
So it's a balance there that
we haven't yet drilled on
where we want to support.
So filters-- it's a new concept
in the YouTube API.
They're applied to lists,
in particular.
And what we're trying to say is
that every single list, if
it's unfiltered, it's supposed
to return the entire index
YouTube has.
So if you're doing list videos,
supposedly we're being
asked to return the entire
index of all videos ever
YouTube had in one request,
in one response,
which is not feasible.
So in order to cope with that
and to basically give people a
clear notion of what it can do
to filter, to narrow down the
number of results a particular
API method will affect, we
added a particular process
called Filter.
So every single YouTube API list
request has to specify at
least one filter, and actually
at most one filter, too.
So you cannot combine filters.
But there can be extra
parameters that define how the
filter works.
A couple of filters that I want
to talk about, one of
them-- the most important
one-- is the ID filter.
And we took it a bit further
in just allowing you to
retrieve a single
resource by ID.
We allow you to retrieve any
number of resources you want
by [INAUDIBLE]
number.
We actually have a high limit
of 50 that we support.
But it's a comma-separated list
of IDs that you can put
in the ID parameter.
And that matches, from the
entire collection, only those
resources that have that
ID, for instance.
Another filter that maybe is a
lot more interesting to see
are the playlistitems.
Playlistitems is the collection
of all entries in a
playlist, if you want.
So not all playlists.
So there are playlists, and then
there are entries inside
a playlist, videos inside
a playlist.
So that's playlistitems,
if that makes sense.
OK?
All right.
So that was you can filter by
a particular playlist ID.
So the code there is exactly,
give me all the
videos in this playlist.
And that's the filter
playlist ID.
And for search, of course, you
have filter by textual
keywords that you want to
match when you return.
And there is a particular one,
the mine filter, that just
returns data that belongs to
the [? character of the ?]
user.
So whatever you uploaded,
whatever you
created is in a playlist.
And on changing the behavior of
a particular filter, I have
here an example where you search
for a particular term,
like APIs, and you want to
change the order in which the
results are returned.
So then there is an extra
parameter, which is not a
filter, but it's just a normal
parameter that affects how the
response actually looks like.
And that's the order
it was rated.
So you want to sort
them by rating.
AUDIENCE: What--
RAUL FURNICA: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: --about page number?
RAUL FURNICA: How about?
AUDIENCE: Page number.
Page.
RAUL FURNICA: Page number?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, if I only
want a certain--
RAUL FURNICA: I'm going to talk
about that in two slides,
If I Remember right.
So all services in YouTube API
define to particular filters--
the ID filter, which allows
us to return one or more
resources by ID, and
the mine filter.
The mine filter is an
interesting one, because it
actually requires you to fire
an authenticator request.
So if you're trying to use the
mine filter, but you're not
authenticated as a user, then it
doesn't really make sense.
So you don't really have
anything as a public API call.
And also, it allows you to build
an app that manages the
user's account if you want, or
just adding those features to
an app that already exists.
And let's talk about paging.
As I said, in two slides.
So paging is the other option
you have to reduce the number
of resources that will
be returned on
a particular request.
And in v3, we have
changed paging.
And this is a big change
versus v2.
In v2, the paging was indexed.
So you would only say, start
index 25, num results five.
You have a question?
OK.
So that meant for us that we had
to return, from the 25th
resource that matched,
five resources.
And in v3, we're using
token-based paging.
The reason for that is that we
get more flexibility to both
give you consistent paging-- so
if the collection changed
since you first requested the
previous page, you would
actually either see duplicates,
like resources
that you saw in the previous
page [INAUDIBLE], because you
can actually tell when you
actually did that request.
Tokens allow us to do a much
better job at that.
That doesn't mean we're doing
it on all requests yet, but
that's where we want to be.
And the way it works is that
on every response,
you have a page info.
So it tells you what are the
total number of resources that
matched your filter.
And it tells you how many
results per page we have
returned, which is always
identical to the parameter you
sent over that says
maxResults=10 or whatever.
The default is five right
now [INAUDIBLE].
And we also give you the next
page token and the previous
page token, so for navigating
back and forth.
That's the token you would
use in the page
token for your parameter.
And that would retrieve this
particular page now.
So in that sense, the API
interface simplifies
a lot, if you want.
It's not as powerful as index
paging, in the sense that it
doesn't allow you to skip pages
and go to the particular
page that you want directly.
This only allows you
to go page by page.
AUDIENCE: So the PageToken,
I need to get
that from the response.
RAUL FURNICA: Yeah.
So you can't just
skip 10 pages.
AUDIENCE: Oh, bummer.
RAUL FURNICA: Yeah, that's the
difference between the index
paging and the token paging.
AUDIENCE: Are you going
to [INAUDIBLE]?
RAUL FURNICA: If there is a big
use case, if it's a big
feature request to have that,
we will look into it.
But right now, we're just
happy with it so far.
AUDIENCE: Right on.
AUDIENCE: Could you
repeat questions?
RAUL FURNICA: OK.
So the question is, in fact, are
we going to add a way to
skip pages?
And the answer so far is that
we don't have that.
But if it turns to be a very
important use case to support,
then we would add it.
But basically, your feedback.
AUDIENCE: I would say,
just use numbers.
[INAUDIBLE].
RAUL FURNICA: That would be back
to index paging, which is
the one we actually think it's
inferior in design to
this one right now.
But because of the problems
I mentioned, you get
duplication, because the
collection changes in the time
you're browsing it.
And we can do much better with
this, because the token
actually catches the
type of time--
AUDIENCE: It changes.
RAUL FURNICA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
So it can give you consistent
browsing with tokens.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE].
RAUL FURNICA: Yeah, we token--
so the question is, if the
data behind changes while you're
browsing a collection,
what's the intended behavior?
So the intended behavior is
really that you're not
affected by that.
And your review of the
collection stays consistent,
even though the data
behind it changes.
AUDIENCE: Are there special
values for the tokens when
you're-- begin and
end of the list?
RAUL FURNICA: Are there special
values for the token
at the beginning of the list
or at the end of the list?
Beginning of the list
is marked by an
[? absence of the ?] token.
So that's 0.
End of the list is not something
we're super strong
on, because the more
it grows, the less
we think it's relevant.
Like in search, for instance,
it's not relevant to go to the
millionth response.
But to tell-- if it's a finite
collection, like the items in
a playlist, then you know you
reached t end because you'll
never have a next-page token.
And you also know by the
total results how
many are in that place.
So you don't have a number
directly from
the very first request.
AUDIENCE: What happens if
a video is deleted?
[INAUDIBLE].
RAUL FURNICA: If a video is
deleted, you're going to see
some metadata about
that video.
But of course, you cannot play
back the video anymore.
So it's like with any web
reference, if you want.
You still have the link on a
page about another page that
was deleted.
But once you try to access it,
you can't get anything.
So it's the same thing.
You get the reference
to the video.
You still get the ID.
You might still get
some metadata.
But you will not be able
to view the video.
AUDIENCE: There wouldn't be
any metadata in that, say,
[INAUDIBLE]?
RAUL FURNICA: There is some
metadata that is being
referenced.
So for instance, that's true for
the YouTube website, too.
So if you have a video on your
playlist that you don't own,
somebody else owns, and that
particular person deletes it,
you still see some metadata
about that video.
And the reason for that is
because we need to allow
people to manage their
playlists.
So they need to see that that
video is not available anymore
and then delete the playlist
item and create something or
replace it with something
else.
And also, we don't want to get
into the behavior that we
randomly remove stuff from
people's playlists, and then
they don't know what's
happening.
I've already talked a bit about
the response format,
mainly the default
format is JSON.
And almost everybody is familiar
with JSON by now,
which is one of the big reasons
why we incremented the
major version of YouTube API, to
switch Atom/XML to JSON and
more modern standards and
response formats.
It's lightweight.
It's easy.
It's a textual format.
It's easy to debug.
Everybody understands it.
It's human-readable, it's
machine-readable.
It's a lot more compact
than XML and Atom.
And it is a different
format, as I said.
But we're actually thinking
that if people care about
bandwidth, we can do even
better than that.
So we're working on extended
protocol buffers, which means
we're allowing people to get
binary serialization from us,
which are much more effective
in terms of
bandwidth, even in JSON.
And it is the most efficient
version, but it's also a power
user feature.
So not everybody's going to
use it, I'm pretty sure.
But if bandwidth is really
important, then people are
going to use it, I think.
AUDIENCE: Just curious,
are you still
going to support XML?
RAUL FURNICA: No.
The question was, are we still
going to support XML?
The answer is no.
With the new version comes a
fresh set of client libraries,
which actually are
really awesome.
And you can try them all.
And I have the link, as well,
on the last slide, and I'm
going to leave the last
slide up for a while.
I'm going to send the slides
around, as well.
But we just support a lot of
languages now, compared to v2.
The advantage is that, since
we're building on the same
technology stack as every other
Google API, we get to
the client library support
almost for free.
That's good for us.
It's good for you, as well.
So we're having .NET, Dart,
even a Google Web Toolkit
extension, Java, JavaScript,
Objective-C, PHP, Python, and
Ruby at this point.
And anything that, depends on
how many people are going to
use it, we're going to
add to this list.
So this slide, I don't know if
I've introduced [INAUDIBLE]
before.
Or maybe you know.
Everybody knows [INAUDIBLE].
So he's been an awesome
dev advocate.
And he was complaining when I
was building the slides that
they're kind of dry and we need
some personal information
about you and all that.
So I already told you I'm from
Switzerland and all that.
So this is about me.
We need a break from all the
technical stuff, so let's
check it out.
So that's it.
So that was my first snowboard
jump ever, last year, and the
last one I did.
But basically, the final thing
I want to say is that I like
my extreme programming as I like
my extreme sports, which
means cowardly safe.
Which is good for you, I
think, because I'm not
breaking the API every
month or every week.
But it's kind of like my
philosophy in a sense, or what
I've come to learn in a very
painful way, I might say, with
the recent app that we broke,
or we took back.
And it's like, work on
the API team can be
very back and forth.
So you want to evolve the API,
and you want to do cool stuff,
but then you launch it,
and stuff breaks.
And then you have to take it
back, and you have to figure
out a way to put it out there
in a way that people can use
the new cool stuff but
doesn't break the app
that's already existing.
And fortunately for everybody,
actually, YouTube API is used
by our internal apps,
as well, a lot.
And the Android that we're
having on the Android phone,
for instance, it's using
the YouTube API.
So in that sense, it's the same
API we're using, that
you're using.
And that's good for everybody,
because first, it catches
issues very fast for us.
And second, if you feel like
it's easier for us to ignore
third-party developers, it's
really hard to ignore
first-party developers that
come to the desk, and it's
like, you broke my app.
So you have to fix it.
And that's where the cowardly
safe comes from, because we
did that a couple of times,
and then it's like, OK, we
need to stop doing this, and I
need to stop waking up at 3:00
AM for pushes that broke apps.
And we need to do better.
And I think we actually have
a very good track.
Like, v2 has been around
for five years.
V1 has been around for six years
and is still working.
So I think we're
kind of there.
We're doing it.
So in the next part, which is
the second part of my talk,
I'm going to talk about design
principles and how we've built
and thoughts we were thinking
around building v3.
It may not be very interesting
from a client perspective, but
it may give you more light on
how APIs are being built and
what we consider when
we think about it.
This slide, in particular,
it's not anything
that I came up with.
I just went to Wikipedia, and I
took the generic principles
from there.
So YouTube API is a
service-oriented architecture.
And any RESTful API is that.
So you have services, as I
talked about, and you have
resources that those
services work on.
That means that in itself,
it comes with a couple of
principles, that I list here.
So you have a particular
contract for each service.
People that have to know what
that service does in order to
be able to use it.
You have loose coupling.
So the two different services
shouldn't do the same thing.
The more things you have that
are similar or do kind of like
the same thing, the more
confusing it is in an API.
So you want to keep
that to a minimum.
The service is an abstraction,
so it doesn't tell you about
the back ends or the logic
that's behind it.
It just tells you, this
is what I do.
I don't need to understand
what's behind it.
And that makes it easy
to use the API.
The service is also usable.
So instead of coming up with new
things all the time, you
should find out ways to reuse
existing services.
So we always have the choice of
writing new services, but
the first question has to be,
do we have already a service
that does this?
Services are autonomous,
so they work
independent of each other.
They are stateless.
That's almost all
web services.
They have a schema that can be
read at runtime, so there is
discoverability And they're
composable, in the sense that
one service can work with
the other, and so on.
And in particular for RESTful,
we care about scalability and
interfaces.
But to go a bit into depth with
this concept, so what
have we done in particular for
the YouTube API v3, related to
those principles?
So the contract of the service
and the discoverability, it's
done via the discovery service
that all Google has.
So any single Google API right
now that is served on
googleapis.com, you can go
to the Discovery Service.
It's that link over there,
developers.googl
e.com/discovery, and then you
can download the schema of
that service and find out what
are the parameters that every
method takes, what are all the
methods [INAUDIBLE] and so on.
Our own client libraries are
using this document to build
their data model.
And also, it's something you
can analyze to do any API
reflection that you
might need.
Or if you're building tools,
like ID extensions for
particular products or
APIs, then you can
integrate with that.
That also contains documentation
and so on for
particular features.
This is a big new thing.
We didn't have anything
like this in v2.
AUDIENCE: Question.
RAUL FURNICA: Yes?
AUDIENCE: So if you have
discovery, are we going to
have something like the
interface definition language?
Like in XML, [INAUDIBLE],
there is a way still to
describe what the service is.
RAUL FURNICA: So we're using
the JSON schema for that.
The question is, if we have
discovery, are we going to
have an idea, or an XML
description language that the
discovery document
is written in?
And the answer is that,
basically, we use JSON schema.
We checked out at
json-schema.org, I think.
And I just pulled it up here so
you can see what a document
looks like.
And it's pure JSON that tells
you the name of the inquiry.
You can see right now, what's
the revision, what is the
description, what are the
items for [? the API? ?]
And then if we go into the
actual definition, you're
going to get authentication
information, [INAUDIBLE]
authentication [INAUDIBLE]
API supports.
And then we get to the schemas,
which tells us every
single resource, what's the
name of the resource.
So you have an activity
resource, and then what are
the fields on that resource.
So we have an ID, type, a
description, and so on.
Every single field
is described with
documentation there.
So the description you see
there is basically the
documentation of that field.
And you can read it right here,
or you can add it to a
client library, or you can use
it to generate a documentation
document or anything
like that.
And later on, down in the
documents, you're going to
find rest of all the methods and
everything else about how
the API can be used, and then
what are the parameters for
each method, and so on.
AUDIENCE: So is this going to be
a standard JSON schema, or
is this Google-specific?
RAUL FURNICA: It's a standard
JSON schema.
We don't do anything
specific here.
The question was if this is a
web standard, or we're just
using some Google-specific
tools.
On to the reusability part, a
good example that I can show
you right now is the
reused playlists.
So there are many ways or many
lists of videos that you can
find on a particular account.
The first request that
I'm showing here,
it's fetching my channel.
So as I'm authenticating as a
particular user, I'm fetching
my channel.
And I'm asking for the content
of that channel.
And in the content of that
channel, there is a field
called Related Playlists.
If you look at the field,
it's a map.
And the names are likes,
favorites, uploads, watch
history, and watch later.
They're all features of
YouTube, but in that
particular playlist
in that sense.
However, they're all playlist
IDs, and they all can be
fetched via the playlist
collection or service.
So in the playlist service, I
can take, into the ID filter,
all those different IDs, put
them in, and I'm going to get
playlists and all the content of
the watch history and watch
later and so on.
So in that sense, if you have
written on the client tab a
playlist player, let's say, you
do not need to deal with
different APIs for the watch
history or the watch later.
You can just feed the same data
to that playlist player,
and it's going to be able to
play back through that.
So any video list is, in
that sense, a playlist.
We could have went the way that
we had different services
and different collections for
it, but reusability, it's a
big principle that we
care about in v3.
Autonomy is the other big one,
which kind of has a good side
of the coin and a bad
side of the coin.
It's no perfect [INAUDIBLE].
And it's also different from
v2, in that from v2, we
approached this differently.
So in v3, every single service
operates on one collection
only, and none more.
So in v2, every single service
could operate on the same
resource as [INAUDIBLE]
services.
So we had playlist service,
which contained videos, and we
had a video service, or an
upload service, that contained
videos as well.
In v3, there is only one
playlist where videos are
being retrieved from, and that's
the video service.
The playlist service
would never
inline a video in itself.
Like, you would have metadata
about the video, but it would
not be a video in that
sense, if you want.
It also ties into inheritance
versus composition.
So resource inlining
is not supported.
The way to make that better
and not say that we cannot
retrieve anything about the
link to resource-- for
instance, in a playlist, you
have various items that are
about video, right?
It's that, as I told earlier,
we have a snippet for every
single resource returning you
get where you can get
information about that
referenced resource.
It's not a lot of information.
And if you need extra
information that only the
video resource has, you need to
fetch the video in the end.
But it gives a starting point.
To give an example of this on
search, which is now actually
on the slides, but on search,
you can find videos, too.
However, in search, it's really
important that we
conserve the bandwidth
and we actually--
it's not so important that we
have a full video description,
for instance.
So the search snippet, it has
also a description field.
But it's not going to inline the
entire video description
but just a snippet of the video
description, which makes
sense, because in search, you
want snippets about the stuff
you matched.
So that's the difference,
if you want.
Search doesn't return videos.
It returns search results.
But those talk about videos.
One other thing to note.
This is that the ID of a search
result is actually a
composed ID.
So it has a kind, which
is the same as the
type of the API response.
So that kind could be
video or playlist.
So you might have matched
the video and playlist.
And then it has the relevant
field of the video or the
channel or the playlist that
the field [INAUDIBLE]
information that you need.
So it's really both autonomous,
like search can
function without the video
field, or the video
collection, and there is
composition there, too.
So search refers to it.
And that's the slide here.
Because I was saying, that's
the reverse of the coin, so
that's the good part.
The bad part is that we don't
get the information about a
video inlined in the
search response.
And in order to get that, we
need to follow up with a
second request.
Now, I talked about
the ID filter.
The ID filter is what
I would like to call
the poor man's batch.
So you can do a batch.
Literally, you can take a number
of up to 15 video IDs
and put them in the ID filter
and return them all at once.
So that means if you're writing
an application, that,
say, you use to display these
items, and you do a request,
like one of those two here, that
returns particular items
in a place.
And those are videos that you
want to have more data fetched
about those videos.
You don't need to follow up.
Say you retrieve 25 playlist
items, you don't need to
follow up with 25 requests.
But you follow up with a see-all
request, where you put
all 25 videos you
want to return.
So it's composed, and it's
different [INAUDIBLE]
services, but we give you tools
to make that easy so you
don't have to query too much and
batch as much as you can.
And that would be a bit about
design principles and how we
applied them to v3.
Next, I'm going to talk about
migration guide and
deprecation of v2.
Is there any particular
question about design
principles in particular?
AUDIENCE: It's pretty good.
RAUL FURNICA: Thank you.
OK, let's talk about v2.
I didn't want to talk
much about v2.
It's like v2 is the past.
v3 is the future.
We're much more excited
about v3.
But that doesn't mean that--
I mean, as I said, we have a
long track of stability in the
YouTube API, and we don't want
to ruin any of that.
So don't worry about v2
going away too soon.
It's going to go away,
but not anytime soon.
It will be supported at least
until April 2015.
We will announce you when it's
officially deprecated.
We didn't deprecate v2 right
now, because we want to add a
bit more features to v3
before we do that.
And v3, we're still
working on it.
And we're adding a lot of
features to help you migrate
existing apps from v2 to v3.
Amongst those, we have
user authentication.
So if you're using OAuth 2.0 in
v2, it's going to work in
v3, too, kind of like
the same way.
The scopes in v2 are accepted
in v3 as well.
The scopes in v3 have
[INAUDIBLE]
in v2.
So once you switch fully to
v3, you're just going to
[INAUDIBLE] there, and you
don't need to fire back
requests with v2, hopefully.
Authenticated, in that sense.
The developer registr--
sorry.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
How do you cases where your
developer keys aren't secured
by [INAUDIBLE]?
RAUL FURNICA: The question is,
how do we handle cases where
the developer key can
be [INAUDIBLE]
from the code, like
in JavaScript?
There's not a good answer
for it right now.
So you can put the developer key
in a header, but if it's
JavaScript, you can always
look at the code
and see what happens.
Developer keys aren't sniffable,
in that sense.
We can't really super-secure
them all the
time for all cases.
AUDIENCE: Is there a way to
specify that there's an
anonymous developer or
something like that?
RAUL FURNICA: That's another
good question.
So is there a way to specify
that it's anonymous developer?
The version 3 doesn't allow
unregistered traffic.
So in version 3, every single
call you make, you have to
have a developer key for it.
So in that sense, there is no
way to do anonymous calls.
So yeah, there is no good answer
for JavaScript, in
particular, for [INAUDIBLE]
or clients.
There is a way to hide it if you
have a server application,
and then you put it on
the server and not
on the client side.
But that can be harder to
do than it is to stay.
So we're aware of it,
and we're kind of
fine with it so far.
If we find there is a lot of
abuse happening because of
that, then we're going
to look into it.
But it's a good question that I
don't have a good answer to.
And because we're talking about
developer registration
in particular, if you register
with v3 today, you're going to
be able to use the same
developer key in
v3 and v2 as well.
So the only thing you need to do
if you want to keep firing
requests against both v2 and v3
for a while, and they have
a migration in steps, and that
switch on the site is starting
using v3 developer keys.
And resource IDs are
interchangeable between the
two versions of the
API as well.
Any particular questions
about migration?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
RAUL FURNICA: I can't
really hear you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
RAUL FURNICA: [INAUDIBLE].
RAUL FURNICA: Do you
mean video tags?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]?
RAUL FURNICA: It's
a good question.
So I think back here somewhere,
I was showing the
video schema.
Yeah.
And you actually do have
tags on the schema.
But recently, YouTube has
removed video tags from read.
So they're not publicly
accessible.
However, tags are still
there, and they're
accessible to the uploader.
That's a product decision
on the YouTube side.
On the API side, we don't have
much to say about it, or we
don't have any particular
reasoning.
And I think a PM would
be much better
to answer that question.
Or maybe do you have
more details?
PRESENTER: Yeah.
The answer is, [INAUDIBLE]
so if you were using
[INAUDIBLE]
to be talking about a specific
set of [INAUDIBLE], API that
allows you to do [INAUDIBLE]
IDs, and then without
the [INAUDIBLE].
RAUL FURNICA: Yeah.
So I'm going to talk about
topics a bit later, and I'm
going to introduce
it for that.
But this key, [INAUDIBLE]'s
answer was that topics and
[INAUDIBLE].
So let's go into the new
features that we had in v3
that we didn't have in
previous versions.
I'm going to highlight
two in particular.
I did more than that,
but I'm not going to
take too much time.
So universal search
is one of them.
So as I said, we reworked
search.
In version 2, you could search
only on particular indexes.
So you could only search
videos or playlists or
channels, but not
a combination of
those in the same time.
In version 3, we're adding
universal search, which
basically allows you to search
anything at the same time.
Or it still gives you the option
to restrict a search to
a particular resource type,
like just videos or just
channels or just playlists.
I talked a bit about how that
looks like, as a search
result, as a search resource.
But the benefit is that we
get to do the ranking and
relevance on the server side.
So we might not, given different
terms-- like,
channel is the best fit for
a first result versus a
video and so on.
I'm not going to show you
[INAUDIBLE], but the way it
works is that in the search
response, you get the snippet
about the resource matched,
and then the ID of the
resource, if you have
fetched a full
resource that was found.
So the use case we normally
think about is that you show a
list of search results, and then
it's the same thing that
a user clicks on a particular
search result, and it comes to
the details of that resource.
It's kind of like the same API
operations support in that.
And I'm going to show you a
video about Freebase topics
that I'm introducing into the
YouTube API, which is another
very big feature that
we're adding.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Wouldn't it be amazing if
Google could understand that
the words that you use when
you're doing a search, well,
they aren't just words.
They refer to real things
in the world.
That a building is a building,
and an animal is an animal,
and that they're not just random
strings of characters.
If we could understand that
those words are talking about
those real-world things, then
we could do a better job of
getting you just the content
that you want off the web.
-The way Google is trying to
build information about
real-world connections is by
building a knowledge graph.
The Knowledge Graph is about
collecting information, about
objects in the real world.
The object could be a person,
could be a book, could be a
movie, and many other
types of things.
For example, for a famous
person, we collect relevant
data about them, such as
their date of birth, or
how tall they are.
We can also connect that person
to closely related
objects in the Knowledge
Graph.
-Let's say you're interested
in Renaissance painters, or
how about how many women have
won the Nobel Prize.
By understanding the
relationships between things,
be it between painters in the
Renaissance or women and the
Nobel Prize, Google can do a
better job of understanding
what it is exactly you're
searching for.
-One of the first features we
are going to introduce, which
applies the Knowledge
Graph, is a panel
next to the web results.
-When you have a question to
answer, others may have come
to Google already to search
for the same thing.
Google can jump-start your
research process by combining
the information that others
found useful with the
information in the
Knowledge Graph.
-All of the collective human
wisdom that comes through our
search engine, what people are
searching for, tells us what
are the interesting things
to put in our database.
-Take Leonardo da Vinci.
Let's say you wanted to learn
about the most important
Renaissance painters.
You might search for Leonardo da
Vinci because he's the only
Renaissance painter
you know about.
Now you see information right
in the search results that
helps you explore the broader
topic of Renaissance painters.
You'll see some of the most
famous paintings from that
era, like the Mona Lisa, and
discover other painters of
that time, like Michelangelo
and Raphael.
-We're in the early phases
of moving from being an
information engine to becoming
a knowledge engine.
And these enhancements are one
step in that direction.
-As we grow the Knowledge Graph
and make it larger and
richer, we're really excited at
the opportunity we have to
understand more of the users'
queries, to understand more
about the information that's
out there on the web, and
intelligently connect the
two to each other.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
RAUL FURNICA: So this is about
an effort that is Google-wide.
And there is a lot of it
going into YouTube.
So YouTube is figuring out
particular topics to
associate, or particular
Freebase topics that have been
talked about in the Knowledge
Graph, basically, that are
associated with a particular
video or a playlist or a
channel, and that are
relevant for that
playlist or video or channel.
And in the API, we're servicing
those topic IDs,
which are not YouTube
API-specific.
It's actually a fine example of
integrating the YouTube API
with other APIs that are
not YouTube-specific.
And we give you a way to both
discover content by searching
by particular topics, YouTube
content that matches the
topic, and gathering around,
giving a video of what are the
topics that this video
is related to.
The way that looks into the API
response is that we have a
part that is particular
for topics--
called Topic Details--
that lists all the topic IDs
that we think this YouTube
content is associated with.
From there, you can either take
a topic ID and resolve it
against the Freebase API, and
understand what that topic is
about and what is the other
information in the Knowledge
Graph we have about that topic,
or you can search for
more content related
to that topic.
That's a YouTube API call that
you can make to search for
more YouTube content matching
that topic.
To read more about the Freebase
API in particular,
you can use the link
on the side.
Basically, it's a wiki
on freebase.com.
And it explains what topics are
in particular, and how do
you identify it, and how do you
retrieve metadata about
topics, and how do you find all
kind of things about them.
Talking about YouTube API
in particular, this
is one of the examples.
So if I was looking at the video
ID there-- and by the
way, all the video IDs that are
used here are kind of like
talks that are interesting,
that you might
want to check out.
So I didn't choose
random video IDs.
I just chose something that
might send you on a path to
find even more about
either YouTube or
Freebase or YouTube API.
And I'm asking for the topic
details of that video ID.
And I'm getting back a Freebase
topic ID that looks
like that, so slash [INAUDIBLE]
and then slash and
then the ID.
In order to load information
about that topic, by just
seeing the YouTube API response,
I don't really know
what a topic is.
I just have this ID, so I don't
really know the name of
the title of the topic,
what is it about.
In order to resolve that, we're
going to use right now,
actually, the Freebase API,
which is also a JSON API that
you can use from this
[INAUDIBLE]
Freebase as well.
And I just paste in the
topic ID I got.
And the filter on this
particular API restricts the
data you return about
that topic.
So the topic the video is
associated with is API.
And it was created by that
particular user at that time.
And it was that title
in English.
And there is a lot more if I
were to either include more in
the filter or just take
the filter out.
Actually, I can just try it out
and show you that it's a
lot of rich information in the
response of the Freebase API.
So you get alias topics.
You get articles you read
on Wikipedia APIs.
You also are going to see some
thumbnails, pictures, video
talks about APIs, and so on.
It's all embedded in the
Knowledge Graph, if you want.
So you can take any YouTube
resource, find the topics
associated, go to the Freebase
API, find what the topic is
about, and find content that is
not even YouTube-related--
it's not on Wikipedia
or anything else--
and pull all that
data and show it
in your app, basically.
Which should be better
[INAUDIBLE].
And then, assuming we had
resolved that, or we figured
out what the topic is about, and
maybe other content that
is not YouTube-specific about
that topic, we might want to
search more videos or more
channels that have that topic
as well, or share that topic.
The way to do that is, in the
search API, just pass on the
topic ID as a parameter.
And you can specify extra
search keywords, or not.
And that's going to return you
even more YouTube content that
is associated with that topic.
And we have a cool sample client
application that I can
show you right now.
And this is using the search.
It's a very simple UI.
We didn't want to do too much.
But we just want to show you
the API call and how
it would look like.
So for instance, I'm going to
search for the API topic that
we just had before.
This is textual search in
topics, so it's going to just
match topics right now
related to API.
It has a very good suggestion
and a very strong suggestion--
API, Application Programming
Interface.
That's the one I
actually meant.
But there are actually
other topics that
are related to APIs.
And they are showing here.
I can pick that one, which just
means picking the ID that
you saw before.
And as a result of that, firing
a search with the
YouTube API, I get channels
about the API, about APIs.
I get playlists about APIs.
So there is an AdWords place,
there is an About
Apigee, and so on.
And I get videos about APIs that
I can all search through
universal search.
How to design a good
API, and so on.
AUDIENCE: So is that prioritized
through relevancy?
RAUL FURNICA: The client
application here is actually
doing the [? splitting. ?]
It shows the type of
channels versus
playlists versus videos.
But normally, if you just typed
a response for the API
server, it's going to be
relevancy, and they're going
to all intermingle.
Or you can restrict to just
videos, or just channels, or
just playlists.
AUDIENCE: So in this client
[? support ?] area, the filter
is the same [? text box ?]
API--
Google--
RAUL FURNICA: Yeah, I can.
AUDIENCE: Is that the order of
relevancy, the APIs that are
the most relevant?
Google is probably
[? secondary-- ?]
RAUL FURNICA: Oh, you mean--
so the question is if API
is more relevant.
You mean amongst topics?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, if I say API--
RAUL FURNICA: Like here.
AUDIENCE: space,
Google space--
RAUL FURNICA: So I'm not sure
if API google is going to
match a particular
API Google topic.
But it actually matches topics
that has [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
RAUL FURNICA: And you can try
this out, and you can see the
source code of the
app as well.
It's also linked
[? on the site. ?]
So this is my last slide, so
thanks for bearing and being
with me still.
So you have a bunch of links
here that you can follow and
read more about version 3,
try it out, register as a
developer, and try the sample
client application.
So you have the documentation.
The documentation has a tool
that lets you try different
API calls directly from the
documentation page.
So you can both read what is
called as and what are all the
parameters it takes and what
each parameter means, and also
try it in the same time
on the web interface.
The client libraries are linked
there, and we have
nine, ten client libraries
that we support.
The API Explorer lets you fire
API requests on the web
interface as well without having
to go through developer
registration.
You can just try it out on the
web interface directly.
The Developer Registration and
Console is a great tool to
monitor your particular client
application API traffic and to
register for either just YouTube
API or other APIs that
you are using in your
application--
Google APIs, I should say.
The resources [INAUDIBLE], and
we have a team of DevRel and
people that, even us apps
engineers sometimes come on
the pones and answer questions
that third-party
developers ask us.
And that's on Stack Overflow.
And there is a YouTube API
tag for it you can use.
The API itself, it's
[? served ?] from
googleapis.com/youtube/v3.
The discovery document that I
talked to you about, where you
can read the schema, both
human-readable and
machine-readable, and the
client applications.
PRESENTER: [INAUDIBLE].
Going once.
Sold.
OK.
RAUL FURNICA: Thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]